You know,
Adam Russell brand with doctor,
professor Dr to Professor Julian ps,
and you've got to join us and watch and
listen to under the skin.
What did we talk about?
Oh God,
it was deep.
Was everything under the sun?
Yeah.
You're,
you're an exhausting interviewer in the
best possible.
We really,
really enjoyed it.
I think it was a good open conversation.
I think we,
we went through a lot topics such as we
talked about there,
uh,
controversies that you've been involved
with.
Even some of my control vcs,
if you enjoy it.
We talked about inequality.
We told her that in American attorneys.
You talked about politics,
how the temperament means,
what words mean where power lies.
I mean,
it's pretty good conversation.
We both have got vague headaches.
I feel a bit sort of exhausted.
This would probably be the big way we
would say something stupid.
So please listen to under the skin and a
whoa.
Just to be alive,
to be alive.
Really.
But one thing you could do,
you could do that and to that within the
scope of your freedoms.
Right?
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much,
ma'am.
Yeah,
under the skin.